a former Minneapolis police officer
could face more than 15 years in prison
for shooting and killing an unarmed yoga
teacher Mohammed nor was found guilty
yesterday of murdering Justine Damon nor
was responding to Damon's 9-1-1 call
nearly two years ago when he opened fire
Dean Reynolds is outside the courthouse
in Minneapolis where the verdict was
handed down Dean good morning good
morning the jury reached a decision
after deliberating for roughly 11 hours
finding Neuer guilty of murder in the
third degree and manslaughter in the
second degree but acquitting him of the
more serious charge of murder in the
second degree this welcome conviction
will not bring Justine back however we
celebrate that some form of justice has
occurred this week friends and family of
Justine Damon breed the sigh of relief
following Tuesday's guilty verdict
against former Minneapolis police
officer Muhammad nor we believe he was
properly charged with a crime while
Damon's father said he was satisfied
with the outcome
Damon's fiance criticized the
Minneapolis Police Department but that
night there was a tragic lapse of care
and complete disregard for the sanctity
of life on July 15 2017 newer and his
partner were responding to Damon's 9-1-1
call about a possible sexual assault
near her home while searching for a
suspect from inside their patrol car
Nour testified that he heard a loud slap
on the driver's side of the vehicle and
shot daymond from the passenger seat out
of fear for his partner's life the
month-long trial hinged on whether Knorr
use of deadly force was justified
Minnesota law allows officers to use
deadly force if they perceive a threat
but defense attorneys could not convince
the jury Damon's alleged slap justified
the shooting well the evidence showed
that the officer acted unreasonably
Hennepin County Attorney Mike Freeman
says nor is the first Minnesota police
officer to be convicted of murdering
someone while on duty it does not give
us pleasure to call out police
is wrongdoing but when it occurs it is
our job to let the public know and in
extreme cases to bring charges and
prosecution
now the police and the police union
leaders say they respect Tuesday's
verdict the judge in the case denied
bond to nor who is due back in court for
sentencing on June 7th so far no word on
whether his defense attorneys plan to
appeal Gale alright thank you very much
Dean